luca's with us in san antonio hey luca
welcome
to the ramsey show how can we help how
you doing today thank you so much for
taking my call
sure what's up um i'm calling because i
am 28 years old
i have a wife and i have two little
girls and i'm looking to
start getting into becoming a real
estate agent but i don't want to be one
of those slime balls you know
and i just want to know what advice you
would have or any thoughts you would
have for getting into this in 2021
we have no debt paid for my wife's full
in all cash
and we own our vehicles the only thing
is that we live in an apartment
we don't have a house yet and that's
kind of wanted to know what your
thoughts were
i'm becoming a real estate agent what do
you uh what do you make a year
um this past year together with my wife
and i we only made forty thousand
dollars
okay what do you make and what does she
make
okay she makes so she makes um thirty
two thousand dollars
and this year since i lost my job in
2020
i was really working with immigrant
shelters and kids weren't coming so they
laid us off so
i was kind of here and there with jobs
throughout the year trying to kind of
bring in what i could
so just total was forty thousand but
before i was seven years
the social service is making about
thirty six thousand dollars okay and but
today what are you making
at this moment okay today um
i'm making thirty if annually will be
thirty four thousand dollars
okay so you've gotten another job yes i
have another job right now okay
you said you're 28 correct 28.
yes sir good great well i think you got
a wonderful goal
uh why is it you want to get in the real
estate business
you know i've i've um i just i love
i've done the church thing i've been in
church kind of i've done the leadership
stuff i love making
um impacts with people and making
community and making connections with
people i'm a people person
and one sense i kind of want to be my
own boss um and i i've always had this
thing to want to become an entrepreneur
but i've always been afraid of it and i
feel like
real estate it's not it just gives me
this
drive to want to be able to say hey i
can help people like myself who've never
had a home
and never see that come to life and be
able to be on the other side of that
very good okay well i think you should
do it
uh if i can figure out a way if i'm you
i'm going to do it incrementally not all
at once
meaning not walk in and quit your day
job so i would start talking to real
estate brokers in your area
and see if you can get on there's a lot
of
high production real estate agents like
the ones in our elp program
that might have a two or three person
team
and they one of those people might have
an entry-level position where you get
licensed and you do some of the grunt
work around the real estate business and
learn the real estate business
working for them and that's your
that's your gateway into moving out on
your own eventually
okay but finding a broker that will let
you incrementally learn this and
some kind of part-time or joining a team
for some kind of minimal guarantee
while you get your license and learn the
business being mentored
like an apprenticeship in a sense if you
can get engaged in something that feels
like that
then that's gonna do it the good news is
you don't have to sell a lot of houses
to make thirty four thousand dollars
so uh but but you're a long way i mean
you gotta get licensed
you've gotta learn a lot of stuff you
don't know today uh before that first
sale is going to occur
and so you need to get under somebody's
tutelage and i can see where
you would think i'm just going to go out
and start selling houses
and there's a lot of things behind the
scenes that you just got to pick up
right
yeah and in this world today the
marketing in the real estate business
is not it's not just as simple as saying
yeah there's a full you know digital
platforms there's
methodologies that you'd use for
gathering clients and communicating with
clients and
um a lot of that costs money yeah and
you know getting plugged into that stuff
and learning how to do that in today's
real estate world
um you know a lot of people don't even
use a phone
uh you know they're just they're texting
i mean they use it for texting or email
and
but the number of times someone's
talking on a telephone
in our world today is a lot less than it
was five years ago
and that's certainly true even where
there's a lot of people interaction
um you know i bought a piece of real
estate uh
last week and i'm closing on it tomorrow
and um as an investment
and um i've not had a telephone
conversation
i won't be at the closing it'll all be
done digitally
uh everything will be wired you know and
that's a different world than when i got
my real estate license in 1978.
so those are the kinds of things you got
to be able to get your head around
if you're going to move into this luca
but i think you should and could do it i
think you can do it don't you
got a special heart man absolutely and
uh
i love they don't they don't have a lot
of money they don't make a big salary
and they're still
cash flowing they're still grinding it
out he's got two little girls that
they're taking care of i just i love the
spirit and
man i got lucky with a real estate agent
with great character
and i want to see more of them out there
so go get em man amen